hold that too oh my gosh it was crazy I
had a single mom of myself who said she
would not submit to a guy unless he made
six figures and I was like well she was
a single mom yeah
yeah anybody that uses the six figure
I won't do this unless it's six figures
that's a red flag
odds are they don't even know anyone
that makes six figures
legitimate six figures it's Escape it's
a red flag so I understand
that's like me saying breast size or
some [ __ ] like that you know what
because you know what I ask I ask would
you quit your job if you told you to
actually I feel like that's like
ultimate submission yeah right is if you
trust him right and they like they'll go
through all this stuff and like be like
no no he has to make this much money but
I'm like girl you can get another job
yeah there's a few quit like you can get
it oh yeah you can get eventually you
get another job right you're right right
yeah but if it doesn't work out like
literally do you get you
yes that's too form of submission this
is she if she quits her job she's
serious about you number one and number
two uh if she direct deposits her
paycheck to your bank account
um
I feel like if you trust him with um
your body I feel like you should be able
to trust him with money your body is
more valuable than freaking money right
right yeah not anymore but I get what
you're saying again not anymore we trash
our bodies in various different ways but
yeah I get what you're saying
yeah women typically are throwing their
bodies around here recklessly and they
think that some reason guys are going to
overlook that and some men do but it
doesn't it's not the man that they want
well when you think about it all men
kind of do because like
what
1950s for
these guys who pray for that nowadays
yeah guys guys have prayed in Jesus she
says too he's like what I couldn't
believe it yeah yeah fair fair enough
you know what I mean but she grew up in
Los Angeles
yeah yeah but you see what I'm saying if
it was legit
so it's like in a way all men kind of
accept it because like Again by 1940s
30s 20s standards everyone's a horror
correct so we're living in horror
culture Horticulture that's what we we
live in a horror culture and uh yeah
that's what we're we're facing the
consequences of that yeah women can't
get married or women are struggling
struggling getting married and men are
cautious of women everyone knew about
these baby mamas raising children I
swear to God I get so confused after my
shows I swear to God I've been ruined
I've been ruined because these girls
would come on the show and they'll talk
about their stuff
and they'll leave and I'll what I do is
before the show I do a picture with them
and I tag them in my story
oh yeah I'm nosy sometimes I follow them
if they're kind of cool yeah
and the girls
on Instagram
oh right yeah and then I'm like I'll see
their stories and I'm like why are you
out three days a week where are your
children
where are your children I'm like my
mother and she's out clubbing I would be
mortified right if you were a kid and
you knew your mom was out clubbing yeah
right yeah well these are hookers by the
way
the oh the singles I was just I was
shocked I put that on my story the other
day I'm like all y'all have single moms
going out three days a week where are
your children and then my next story was
if you pass on your kids to your parents
then you are selfish and you're making
someone else deal with your problem and
and everyone and everyone responded to
this story like this was crazy I'm like
and you know who will be absent the
father
yeah in most cases those women will
fight the father to be out of that kid's
life and fight for child support and
that kid you could when you ask where's
the kid when you're out three days a
week nine times out of ten it'll be with
her parents not the father
that's the other thing I realized was a
lot of guys like want to be in their
kids life but they can't because of the
lot like because the child's like the
system is so messed up and I didn't
realize that there's a whole generation
of like mothers that like it you kind of
heard the deadbeat dad narrative but it
really wasn't the deadbeat dads it was
the crazy the bitter mom yes the bitter
mom yeah most I always say most men
found out they didn't have a deadbeat
dad they had a better mom
and so when you find out you had a
bitter mom as an adult you look back and
you go wow you know it's an epiphany for
a lot of men and of course then you have
to arrive do you want the truth
or do you want to live the lie I think
your dad is an [ __ ] the kids aren't
stupid they're gonna grow up and see
that you're a hoe at some point they're
not dumb well women don't think that far
ahead they don't think that far in
advance so they don't think the
repercussions of that and um
unfortunately kids are getting damaged I
think we're doing so much damage to kids
today and um most of it is because we're
selfish men and women but um when it
comes down to these relationship things
we're selfish we don't put the kids
needs first and we think kids are dumb
and we can hide these things from kids
not really your kid's gonna see you for
who you are and uh you might want think
that you can pass this BS and overall
men oh they'll see the value eventually
you know they want and your kids are
going to see that you're a piece of [ __ ]
in the scum of the earth and the scumbag
or a skeezer or deadbeat dad they're
gonna see you see it
the truth comes out eventually
eventually
God I
I don't know you got the truth
because I don't think I'm nice anymore
right well yeah so you're bitter you you
you're the you're the equivalent of
bitter male
so you guys
I I was like whisper but this is what by
the way we have to deal with these type
of women on a very basis
I've been traumatized yeah yeah and I
always tell I want people to answer this
question if you're watching this
um answer this question women typically
don't like other women right it's kind
of known that women defend other women
but there's an instinct that kicks in
where women don't like other women if
they'll do any cat fighting and fighting
kind of manipulative okay now absolutely
now you know the question is
if that's the case if women don't like
women
why should men like women
why
why would because people naturally think
we're supposed to like them the question
is why
why well we don't like other women
because
I feel like well
why
I think women I think like me included
it's like we look for things to get
irritated about sometimes
yeah okay that's fine yeah and so they
use it I I take they basically then use
us if we're in a relationship with them
as the emotional team yeah you basically
have to absorb all their [ __ ] which is
yeah basically but that's a modern
convenience
most marriages and relationships you
might be lucky if you saw your man
like men were blazing Trails they were
trailblazing they were exploring they
were building hunger and Gathering they
were building skyscrapers
like they were doing stuff
and you were settled down with multiple
kids nobody had time for this [ __ ]
see we already live in a safe secure
environment now like men were at War
they were battling they were learning
how to make weapons and defending like
you were just sitting up under each
other or cuddled up afterwards ain't got
time for that [ __ ] so we can literally
just be like all right the woman acting
funny I'll just go out to the shed and
learn how to you know you know I'll go
build the shed you know I mean yeah
I'll go build a bathroom outside you
know what I mean I'll go kill an
alligator I'll go find something to eat
like you can get away from her now but
we got food in the refrigerator we got
everything right here so what else am I
gonna do after work sit up under her
I my opinion is I call it the law of
diminishing return
the more you spend with a person the
more the the relationship or the time's
gonna be messy messed up I agree at some
particular Point you're gonna hit this
line you're going to be like when you
see each other oh you're happy uh then
you're gonna hit that point where every
minute minute spent is gonna be effed up
it's gonna be an argument
misunderstanding miscommunication
malfunction you're bored she wants to do
something she farted you know what I
mean like yeah
yeah so the longer it goes the worse
it's gonna get yeah
people overstay their welcome yeah yep
so it's not looking good for us ladies
we gotta we gotta we gotta stuff up our
game by the way I know I'm not in the
business of correcting women so I I say
Let It Burn yeah I wanted to all caramel
down
what would that look like I think is
going to be the uh Venezuela 2.0 I want
it to be chaos you know why
this is how you learn
you learn when you hit your head as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible